bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de ski mag quel sera le saint
quentin en yvelines de demain avec un
nouveau paysage à 12 communes il s'agit
désormais de construire un projet de
territoire partagé c'est le pari de ski
demain et c'est maintenant que ça
commence c'est parti
[Musique]
et
un
nouveau saint quentin en yvelines est né
en janvier 2016 la loi de modernisation
de l'action publique territoriale et
d'affirmation des métropoles promulguée
en janvier 2014 à redessiner la carte du
territoire ainsi elancourt guyancourt
trappe la verrière montigny le
bretonneux voisins le bretonneux et
magny les hameaux ont vu cinq autres
communes se joindre à elle coignières
les clayes-sous-bois maurepas plaisir
ils prônent désormais forte de ses 80
2000 habitants supplémentaires
l'intercommunalité compte plus de 230
milles saint quentinois répartis sur
cent vingt kilomètres carrés c'est donc
tout un projet qui doit être redéfini la
loi d'orientation sur l'aménagement et
le développement durable du territoire
de juin 1999 offre aux collectivités
comptant au moins 50 mille habitants la
possibilité de s'associer afin de mettre
en oeuvre un projet de territoire
partagé un projet qui détermine les
orientations que se fixent
l'agglomération en matière de
développement économique et de cohésion
sociale d'aménagement et d'urbanisme de
transport ou de logement et qui
détermine aussi les mesures permettant
d'effectuer ses orientations plus que
jamais saint-quentin-en-yvelines
retrousse ses manches pour faire naître
plus d'innovation plus de vivre ensemble
et plus de synergies au sein de
l'intercommunalité
les projets de territoire en règle
générale on les met en place dans dans
des structuration territoriale pour
permettre d'avoir une vision à long
terme sur les 25 30 ans voit au delà
pour pouvoir avoir une espèce de feuille
de route dans tous les secteurs qui nous
importe pour pouvoir je dirais à avoir
une vision sur le lointain de ce qu'on
veut faire notre territoire parmi les
grands projets qui se dessinent les
transports avec la ligne 18 de métro du
grand paris express qui desservira saint
quentin en yvelines est via la future
gare de guyancourt
la commune de magny les hameaux se verra
relié à la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines quant à la gare de la verrière
elle sera améliorée pour répondre aux
nouveaux besoins de la commune et des
collectivités voisines
concernant l'aménagement des routes il
est prévu de recouvrir la nationale 10
afin que la ville de trappes ne soit
plus coupés en deux comme actuellement
est aussi prévue le doublement du pont
schuller à nos repas afin de désengorger
la circulation et d'instaurer une ligne
de transport en site propre on va devoir
travailler là-dessus avec non seulement
je dirais une une vision d'avenir mais
aussi une vision dans vie c'est pour ça
que nous allons travailler avec des
partenaires qui sont sur le territoire
aujourd'hui des partenaires et en
premier lieu les élus joséphine coleman
ce berger a rencontré les maires de
chacune des communes du territoire ainsi
que les différentes directions de saint
quentin en yvelines afin de fédérer
autour de ce projet un projet qui se
veut collectif en septembre dernier une
première assemblée plénière a ainsi
réuni les représentants des douze
communes saint-quentinoise une première
étape pour lancer le mouvement la
deuxième étant la rencontre avec les
habitants et la concertation auprès de
ces derniers ainsi les 12 et 19 novembre
dernier les élus ont effectué ensemble
de visite du territoire afin d'expliquer
aux saint quentinois le projet ce qui
demain autres partenaires le coc des
skis le conseil de développement de
saint quentin en yvelines renouvelé en
mai dernier les membres de coder ce qui
sont désignés par le président et les
élus de saint quentin en yvelines son
objectif conseiller les élus de
l'agglomération en matière de
développement économique financier ou
concernant la vie associative
l'aménagement du territoire ou de
logement la nouveauté
dans ce nouveau connaissent qui qui
vient d'être installé par le président
de gier c'est que les 96 membres de ce
que les skis ont été désignés pour un
quart d'entre eux par le président de
saint quentin michel augier et pour les
3/4 ans par les maires des douze
communes qui constituent aujourd'hui le
nouveau saint quentin les 96 membres du
cos des skis sont issues du monde
économique et associatif
ce sont aussi des habitants et des
experts qui viendront apporter leur avis
aux élus et alimenteront les diverses
étapes du projet ce qui demain dès
novembre 2016 et jusqu'à février 2017 se
déroulera la phase de diagnostic et la
définition des enjeux du nouveau
territoire à 12 communes de février à
avril 2010 est débutera la phase de
définition de la stratégie territoriale
et des grandes orientations futures
d'avril à juin déclinaison de la
stratégie en un programme d'actions
concrètes juin juillet 2010 cette
adoption du projet de territoire en
conseil communautaire à noter que 2
novembre 2016 à juin 2017 se tiendront
des réunions publiques afin de concerter
les saint quentinois
des saint quentinois qui sont d'ores et
déjà invités à apporter leurs
témoignages il ya des textes photos et
vidéos par mail et via les réseaux
sociaux nous sommes nous mêmes partis à
la rencontre des saint-quentinoise et
des saint quentinois afin de recueillir
leurs impressions et leurs souhaits pour
le saint quentin en yvelines de demain
se fait 27 ans que je vis dans la région
je suis bien très bien les points
positifs ce qu'il y à pas mal de grandes
surfaces elle est transparent il ya
beaucoup d'activités j'aime bien le
concept rue piétonnière comme ça et à
des restaurants ils ont amélioré même
les jardins des auto-écoles
disparaît un peu tout ce que j'aime
selon la verdure en revanche bon ce que
j'aime moi c'est quand même du groupe il
circule à sion et quoi améliorer ce
serait le deuxième centre commercial de
centre de skywest qui lui est carrément
vides et on a pu ré assez dommage vous
monter peut-être le nombre de parkings
plus de surveillance peut-être dans 51
divine même la nuit je sais pas si en
fait beaucoup
pour les jeunes mais par contre pour les
personnes âgées il n'ya pas grand-chose
améliorée au décès des impôts locaux et
fonciers et les entreprises dans tout ça
on a un gros réseau au niveau des
entreprises qui nous accompagnent
dans la création des sociétés c'est un
gros avantage qu'on a dans cette
agglomération je vis ici depuis plus de
40 ans et toujours eu du mal en partant
de trappes ou montigny à rejoindre
plaisir et c'est le premier que l'on
rencontre aujourd'hui dont on espère
réellement que l'arrivée de plaisir et
des nouvelles villes dans
l'agglomération permettra une
amélioration des transports ce que
j'aurais souhaité c'est un
accompagnement depuis le début du projet
en fait parce que c'est un peu le
parcours du combattant pourtant dès lors
on connaît pas trop les les démarches à
faire et donc on se retrouve tout seul
noyer dans un brouhaha artistique de
choses administrative aujourd'hui si on
veut trouver des salariés on se dirige
vers pôle emploi on n'a pas de personnes
en charge réelle de ce genre d'activités
mais pôle emploi c'est encore difficile
comme ce qui serait bien c'est qu'on est
des locaux moins cher avoir possibilité
d'avoir des dépôts sur la région saint
quentin en yvelines parce qu'il ya quand
même beaucoup de locaux qui sont vides
et malheureusement on est quand même
beaucoup de mal a justement à trouver un
dépôt pour pouvoir stocker justement
tout le matériel autre son de cloche
celui des associations alors que ce soit
elle pour ce nouveau territoire une
bonne communication avec les différentes
entités adhérentes chez nous et qui est
effectivement de nous faire connaître
sur le sur le territoire on parle
souvent des moyens et quand on parle de
moyens on pense souvent au financement
et aux subventions
je crois qu'il faut surtout qu'on parle
des moyens techniques d'abord c'est à
dire des installations nous sommes
aujourd'hui à gagarine sa nouvellement
construits par la ville de trappes qui
nous a fait un bien fou
dans notre capacité à accueillir autant
d'enfants les infrastructures
précisément sont majeurs et bien sûr ça
nécessite de financement ce qui est
important c'est cette cohésion qu'on
doit avoir de tous les services qu'ils
souhaitent ceux de l'agglo qui soit ceux
de l'état du département en gros que
toutes les collectivités locales se
prennent par la main et travaillent
ensemble on pourrait très bien imaginer
quelque chose de saint quentinois où on
pourrait mutualiser
habitants entreprises associations une
fois les témoignages recueillis que se
passe-t-il on va commencer le vrai
travail et il y aura trois intervenants
dans cette affaire une première
intervenants c'est saint quentin en
yvelines et des services et lisible
deuxième intervenant site une
une entreprise de d'assistance à
maîtrise d ouvrage et troisième
intervenant ce seront des membres du cos
des skis trois intervenants qui débute
dès ce mois de novembre un travail
d'inventaire sur les aspects positifs
est moins positif du territoire s'en
suivra la phase de définition d'axés
stratégiques ou comment définir un
nouveau territoire et ses axes de
développement jusqu'à l'action à savoir
la mise en oeuvre dès l'été prochain
avec ses douze communes le territoire
conforte sa place de deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien après la
défense et devient le premier pôle
commercial des yvelines le développement
économique déjà à la pointe à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines demeure malgré
tout un atout crucial pour l'avenir
ikea jc decaux le nôtre zodiac aerospace
elles ont toutes choisi de s'implanter à
saint quentin en yvelines mais pas
seulement de la tpe à la multinationale
les seize mille entreprises que compte
l'agglomération ont développé 145 mille
emplois engendrant l'un des pib par
habitant les plus élevés de l'hexagone
sans oublier les divers pôles
d'excellence du secteur de
l'aéronautique de l'automobile du
numérique qui font la fierté de la
communauté d'agglomération aujourd'hui
classé double à par les agences de
notation un autre classement fait
également la renommée de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines celui du hem
haïti l'institut technologique du
massachusetts qui compte l'agglomération
parmi les huit zones mondial
d'innovation pour autant pas question de
se reposer sur ses lauriers tron veut
que 50 ans soit un démultiplicateur de
croissance un multiplicateur
d'innovation
bien sûr d'emplois et de et de qualité
de service un projet de croissance qui
passe notamment par l'instauration de
nouveaux produits financiers pour les
entrepreneurs on a déjà des produits
qu'on essaye d'améliorer
bien entendu il faudra que au niveau
national on est toutes les autorisations
pour tester ces nouveaux modes de
financement mais voilà tout ça est en
cours on entre dans une dynamique quand
même très
très positive positif comme cet
incubateur qui ouvrira ses portes le 8
décembre et où tous créateurs de
start-up pourra bénéficier de conseils
d'experts de soutien financier et
logistique
ces derniers seront accompagnés dans
leurs démarches et le lancement de leur
société par l'agglomération au total
trente créateurs seront sélectionnés
il y aura peut-être un des sceaux dedans
il y aura peut-être un bon il y aura
peut-être un deux qu il y aura donc on
est on est là pour qu'on sélectionne les
30 de saint quentin qui ont vraiment une
idée et quel que soit leur revenu en
quelque sort diplômé l'agglomération
soutient également les entreprises par
le biais du small business act qui
permet de créer du lien entre les
petites et grandes entreprises du
territoire
les sociétés des cinq nouvelles communes
bénéficient désormais de ces mêmes
avantages tous les chefs d'entreprises
de tous secteurs d'activité peuvent
ainsi tissé des liens afin d'enrichir le
territoire de ses multiples savoir faire
saint quentin en yvelines c'est aussi
une carte postale entre ville et
campagne
un équilibre auquel les saint quentinois
sont très attachés il s'agira dans ce
projet de respecter les caractères et
spécificités des unes et des autres
communes tout en avançant vers l'avenir
mais à 12,7 fois
[Musique]
tous
plus on est nombreux plus on peut
mutualiser plus en plus mettre en commun
et plus on est riche que ce soit le
monde associatif la culture les
entreprises c'est un écosystème comme on
dit aujourd'hui cet écosystème il
fonctionne si chacun des acteurs de
l'écosystème il trouve sa place et sa
part je peux vous dire qu'on a beaucoup
d'ambition parce que on a une pépite on
a 12 pépite mais on a la paix pic de la
stib aujourd'hui on a un potentiel
incroyable
le coup d'envoi de ces concertations qui
se dérouleront jusqu'à l'été prochain
aura lieu le 29 novembre au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
n'hésitez pas vous aussi à apporter vos
témoignages sur le site de
l'agglomération et sur les réseaux
sociaux à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]